legal troubles are deepening for new
york's embattled governor andrew cuomo
one of his accusers has filed a criminal
complaint alleging cuomo groped her
he denies touching anyone
inappropriately on friday the governor's
legal team tried to punch holes in the
state attorney general's report that
alleges cuomo
sexually harassed 11 former and current
female staffers
michael george is here with the latest
on this michael good morning
jeff good morning in just a few hours
we'll hear from the albany county
sheriff
about a complaint they received against
governor cuomo it's the first sign he
may face a criminal investigation
meanwhile the governor through his
lawyers is pushing back against his
accusers
governor cuomo already in a political
firestorm
could now face a criminal one one of 11
women accusing cuomo of sexual
harassment
identified as executive assistant one
filed a criminal complaint with the
albany county sheriff's office
telling cbs news and the albany times
union what he did
to me was a crime he broke the law
earlier this week an independent
investigation concluded cuomo routinely
harassed women around him
the assistant claims in 2019 and 2020
the governor engaged in close and
intimate hugs on multiple occasions
including one incident when he reached
under her blouse
and grabbed her breast the governor
denies the allegations
let me be clear that never happened on
friday cuomo's attorney rita glavin
attacked the investigation
calling it unfair instead of acting as
independent fact finders
the investigators acted as prosecutors
judge and jury cbs news legal expert and
analyst ricky kleman says the governor
will likely face a criminal prosecution
is it possible he could do jail time yes
it is is it
likely i would say probably not governor
cuomo would
qualify as a first offender he has no
other
criminal record an impeachment probe has
already begun
in the state assembly and members say
they have the votes to impeach
a source tells cbs news cuomo has no
intention of resigning
and that impeachment trial could begin
in a month we've also learned at least
one accuser plans to file a civil
lawsuit against the governor it was
really interesting to watch that news
conference yesterday with his attorneys
michael thank you very much